what is set forth here is the mode and
relationship of the unchangeable has
appeared as the experience through which
the divided self-consciousness passes in
its wretchedness now this experience it
is true is not its own one-sided
movement for it is itself the
unchangeable consciousness and this
consequently is at the same time a
particular individual consciousness -
and the movement is just as much a
movement to the unchangeable
consciousness which makes its appearance
in the movement just as much as the
other for the movement runs through
these moments first the unchangeable as
opposed to individuality in general then
I've been being itself an individual it
is opposed to another individual and
finally it is one with them but this
reflection so far as it is made by us is
here premature for what has come before
us so far as only unchangeable as
unchangeableness of consciousness which
for that reason is not genuine
unchangeableness but one still burdened
with an antithesis not the unchangeable
in and for itself
we do not know therefore how the latter
will behave here we know only that for
consciousness which is their object here
the determinations indicated a bomb
appear in the unchangeable
in Section 211 Hegel appears to be
engaging in a kind of summarization and
repetition of what he did in 209 and 210
but he's introducing another wrinkle to
this or you might say reintroducing
something that we're going to lose sight
of very easily and this is well worth
thinking about in general terms and
hopefully we'll get to do that in a
moment I want to begin where he begins
and where the paragraph actually ends
he's going to talk about the experience
there there farro in German that the
unhappy consciousness or that the the
consciousness has of being unhappy even
it's split and it's vitae literally sort
of doubled away State so what we've seen
so far running throughout this this
motif of the unhappy consciousness is
that there's two sides right and this is
very typical you know through throughout
the Hegelian dialectic consciousness
itself is engaging in a play with its
other and it doesn't realize in this
case that its other is already within
itself then it's not something totally
alien as a matter of fact that's why the
first stage is this this sense that
things are you know totally foreign and
totally other you know the what would
Rudolf Otto in his discussion very
beautiful phenomenological discussion of
the experience of the holy would call
the the numinous or the totally other
ottawa's on is something that the Hegel
is has got is one stage in the
development here now where is this going
to lead to if we take a look at jump
ahead a little bit before we get to this
other stuff where is going to go he says
the reflection insofar as it is made by
us this reflection right here that we're
looking at is here premature for what
has come before us so far as only on
this is unchangeableness of
consciousness that is something within
the play of consciousness where
consciousness is conceptualizing for
itself what the unchangeable would be
and trying to grasp it trying to
understand what is you know transcendent
or absolute importance that which
remains the same that which is eternal
that which is unlike the experience that
we have of the everyday world where
things are you know not completely in a
flux but things don't really last and
meanings that we think are
well-established turn out to when we
look at them closely not measure up as
well as we'd like so he goes on and he
says this is this unchangeableness of
consciousness is not genuine
unchangeableness it's not the fullness
of unchangeableness but one still
burdened with an antithesis not the
unchangeable in and for itself that's
what our goal is to try to grasp and you
could say that part of what's going to
be happening throughout this entire
section is a number of attempts to try
to grasp the unchangeable the eternal
the universal in and of itself and
failing to do that and that human beings
need to go through or at least you know
if they haven't read the phenomenology
and seen where they go hands up they
need to try out this and experience the
the failures through the unhappy
consciousness before they're ready to
instead of just plowing ahead you know
more and more to say oh wait a sec let's
shift gears let's shift position and now
look at this in a different way and
that's part of what's what's happening
here in this this development so he says
we don't know how the Hubble matter the
unchangeable in another in and for
itself is going to behave here we only
know that for consciousness which is our
object here the determination
indicated above appear in the
unchangeable so you know part of what
he's saying is that this progression
that we're going to now look at and
chart out and explore it throughout the
rest of the section is only giving us
part way there it's not yielding us the
unchangeable in and for itself where is
that going to happen
well in its strictest sense that's
really only going to happen in the very
last section of the phenomenology an
absolute knowing but it's sort of like a
willow the wisp that we keep on
following out over and over again
thinking that one determinate shape of
consciousness one you know way of
thinking in a particular epoch one
variety of relations within social
matrix that these somehow become the
absolute and each time we find out no
that's not actually the absolute Hegel
thinks that we do get to the absolutely
at the end but it's something that keeps
on drawing us forward now let's talk
about this whole business here then
right Hegel is going to chart out this
development which now should be rather
familiar to us because we've already
seen it arising in the previous
paragraphs he says the movement runs
through these moments these are the
three moments alright first the
unchangeable is opposed to individuality
in general so as opposed not only to the
individual as the individual who is the
individual consciousness right but it's
also opposed to individuality just as a
category by by virtue of being
individual you are cutting off from the
unchangeable and the two of them don't
really mix together but then again they
do so how does this actually work itself
out and like we said just before one can
sort of cycle around in this this
dynamic over and over and over again
just changing the object of what counts
as the unchangeable so what's the second
he says then being an individual
it is opposed to another individual so
the unchangeable becomes and
individually the unchangeable takes on
determinate Ness answers into history we
could say enters into the social matrix
acquires a language you know we can go
on and on and on thinking about that how
determinacy works in this case but the
main point is that it confronts the
individual who now is moved on to a
service that if confronts it as another
individual we're going to see that that
this individual is a bit different than
the MIS individual right and then the
third is he says finally it is one with
it and this is the unchangeable of the
individual we saw in previous paragraphs
this is where the realm of spirit lies
spirit as involving a kind of
recognition and Reconciliation the
unchangeable and the individual are
related to each other no longer in
conflict but rather are reconciled to
each other there is a resume where the
individual realizes he or she has a
place within the unchangeable now all of
this like Hegel is saying involves the
consciousness of the unchangeable and
it's consciousness as the unchangeable
that we project outside of ourselves
even though it really is us and that's
why we can actually grasp it in the
first place because it is to a certain
extent akin to us this is the more true
more a real state but all too often
we're stuck back here not realizing that
that that is you know what we're tending
towards and individual consciousness
which is the one he actually does
experience experiences unhappiness one
look right why because it doesn't
realize that it's in this doubled state
because in itself is is making that
happen it just thinks that this doubled
state is the way it is
it takes this as being I don't want to
say natural because we might be talking
here about what what you know
theologians called a supernatural over
here right something VI major but it
does take it as natural than that it
takes it for granted as the way
relations must be likewise it takes it
as granted the way relations must be
here the individual as opposed to the
individual I'm making it to spirit it is
an achievement but it's not one that we
can sort of just predict ahead of time
and say oh yeah yeah we just going to
connect the dots and now we're in spirit
we got recognition no it takes a lot of
bitter experience working its way
through now when we're talking about
experience we're not just talking about
individual experience we're also talking
about this in what we could say world
historical terms so the development
various philosophical and cultural and
especially religious attitudes through
systems actual existing systems that
that people live out that is where that
experience takes place and there can be
a progress this way Hegel season from
one configuration to the other so for
example God as the law giver as the the
universal standing over and against the
individual as unfit uribl as not able to
be represented in any sort of graven
image that is one stage and then you
know God has incarnate is going to be a
second stage there's a development
taking place there so what do we have
going out here and reminder that
although we are going to be moving
somewhere it's not such a simple thing
as snapping our fingers and then
skipping over the steps to get here you
have to show your work so to speak and
you show your work through history
for this reason therefore the
unchangeable consciousness also retains
at its very form the basic character of
dividing us
for self in contrast to the individual
consciousness consequently for the
latter the fact that the unchangeable
receives the form of individuality is
only a contingent happening just as it
also merely finds opposed to it so that
the relation seems to result from its
own nature that finally it does find
itself the unchangeable appears to it to
be brought about currently no doubt by
itself or to take place because it is
itself an individual but this unity both
as regards its origin and the fact that
it is appears partly due to the
unchangeable and the antithesis persists
within this unity itself in fact through
the unchangeable is assuming a definite
form the moment of the beyond not only
persists but really is more firmly
established free of the beyond seems to
have been brought closer to the
individual consciousness through the
form of an actuality that is individual
and henceforth on the other hand
confronts him as a nope a sensuous unit
with all the obstinacy of what is actual
the hope of becoming one with it must
remain a hope that is without
fulfillment and present fruition for
between the hope and its fulfillment
here stands precisely the absolute
contingency worried flexible and
difference which lies in the very
assumption of definite form which was
the ground of hope by the nature of this
immediately present unit through the
actual existence in which it has clothed
itself it necessarily follows that in
the world of time it has vanished and
that in space it had a remote existence
and remains utterly remote
in the course of paragraph 212 Hegel is
going to help us understand why the
unhappy consciousness is actually
unhappy we saw that it goes through this
experience that I can't jump right ahead
to the joy spirit and recognition and
all the things that it's been aiming
after instead it has to pass through a
number of attempts to try to make things
come together and finds that that it's
never really able to get there so he
says for this reason the unchangeable
consciousness retains in its very form
the basic character of divided myths and
being for self remember being for self
for Hegel when it's by itself means a
lack of something right it's a B for
self is not entirely to be in and for
itself so it says in contrast to the
individual consciousness so it looks
like the the initiative is now passed
over to the side of the eternal the
unchangeable so it says for the latter
the fact that on the unchangeable
receives the form of individuality is
only a contingent happening just as it
also merely finds itself opposed to it
so that the relation seems to result
from its own nature what are we talking
about there so hingle of saying the
individual consciousness that which
which is doing the you know thinking and
striving and trying to sort things out
but which is contingent also experiences
its own relation to whatever it is the
transcendent the divine the unchangeable
the eternal has shot through with
contingency it just so happens that the
content is that the universal the
non-contingent connects itself up in a
certain way with this guy here right and
it could be didn't have to do that it
could be doing it with somebody else
maybe you know
it could have happened at a different
time in a different place why here why
me these are the sort of questions that
come out of contingency like that so
what is going to be the upshot of this
how is this going to play itself out
there is going to be a lack of
resolution we can say involved in this
so he says when it does find itself in
the unchangeable it that appears to it
to be brought about partly no no doubt
by itself were to take place because it
is itself an individual but this unity
both as regards its origin of the fact
that it is appears partly due to the
unchangeable so even when there's you
know this achievement of you know what
appears to be a reconciliation finding
oneself within the greater unity or
community or economy however we're going
to conceive of it as a bunch of
individuals within this this spiritual
unity that is the eternal there's still
a sense in which well that's not my own
doing it's partly my own doing and it's
partly Who I am but it's really the
initiative of whatever is coming down
from on high and presenting itself to me
so there's two plays of contingency
involved in this there's the contingency
of the individual himself who or herself
who understands their life their work
their labour their desire as contingent
as could be otherwise as perhaps
meaningless as perhaps perched over
nothingness and then there is also the
the you know now there's recognize
something greater at bottom right and if
that thing wants to relate itself to me
that's contingent as well and you could
say well whose fault is it well it's
your own fault because your contingent
so we know of course why would you know
there'd be any non contingency of that
because wait a second that's a that
seems to be a being in which necessity
you know should be residing right so
there must be some sort of nest
Ceri connection to me but can you have a
necessary connection to a contingent
this is this is sort of the background
of metaphysics of what's going on here
Hegel doesn't use the term necessity
here not ven DK but he very well could
now what I've got on the board is not
what what I've just been talking about
I've got what happens afterwards so he
says in fact through the unchangeable is
assuming a definite form the moment of
the beyond the gainsight that that which
is over over there beyond what what it
is that we currently have right the the
moment of the beyond not only persists
but it was really more firmly
established so why is he talking about
the moment to the beyond
well here's the backstory right so
you've got the unchangeable that as
opposed to the contingent individual and
the unchangeable presents itself not
only say as an imperative from above or
as an alien being that you know is
totally wholly in comparison to us
profane slobs or that which is infinite
value as opposed to the merely relative
value that we in our lives possess but
it's also present as this is beyond that
which it is further that we can make
sense of there's there's a kind of
resistance or a kind of void that we
don't even really know what's there it's
beyond right there's there's a limit and
we're not even sure where the limit lies
we just know we're not getting the full
picture so you know think to yourself
for example of ancient religions and
commands coming down from on high and
people say well okay so God wants this
or that of me don't really understand
why but I suppose God must be you know
pretty bright compared to me I'm kind of
stupid and I guess I'll do what he says
and see what happens there's always a
a more there's always a surplus there
that doesn't get explored a you know the
answer to the why ends up spitting out
all sorts of commentary but the
commentary ends up being really just
mere speculation the best that human
beings can do and that's all people need
to dialectical dance but the basic
dynamic is still there that there's a
beyond and it almost tantalizes us or
terrifies us or dismays us or we have
all sorts of effective reactions to it
does that go away when the universal
when the unchangeable becomes an
individual Hegel says no in a certain
sense it seems like it would right and
that is where hope is going to be
brought on the scene an individual comes
in and says I am this unchangeable or I
speak for the unchangeable and now we
can relate to it in a more tangible way
a way that lets us wrap our head around
these sorts of things and say AHA okay I
can I can do things now in relation to
something that I can I can see that I
can grasp yeah that's the hope that's
involved right but is that going to be
realizable not entirely the beyond ends
up existing in the individual even more
then in some sort of you know thing out
there that we're just dimly dumbly
comprehending and trying to worship or
trying to connect ourselves up with when
it's an individual think about our own
relations with ourselves and other
individuals how well do we indeed know
other people have we ever gotten
surprised by the music no I just didn't
have enough information if I was really
really paying
I could really understand another person
and Hinkle would say there is a depth
there is something that it remains in
accessible with the human being
sometimes even to that very human being
Augustine is a great example of somebody
who says I don't really know myself all
the way I know myself pretty pretty well
now I'm not really happy with a lot of
what I know because of you know it turns
out that I'm not really a good guy but a
better of knowing these depths of myself
and these corruptions and things like
that that not knowing myself and all
because maybe now I can cast some light
out of the cat stop you know fix it up
and so never will you pick all sorts of
other people as well if we don't really
know ourselves in our entirety how are
we going to know another individual in
their entirety and if that individual is
the universal how are we going to fully
exhaust that how are we going to
penetrate into the very soul the psyche
the personality whatever it is that the
the divine the transcendent is taking
shape yet so I'm gonna handle talks
about this and some really interesting
terms he says that you know when this is
happening there the beyond seems to be
brought closer to the individual
consciousness through the form of an
actuality that is individual it
henceforth on the other hand confrontive
as an opaque sensuous unity as an other
when we see another person and we look
at their face usually we can have a
pretty good idea of what their
expressions mean sometimes we don't have
a clue right and the same thing can be
said about any other thing that we can
sense gestures right
what gesture am i giving you here it
looks like I saw the saying come closer
but maybe I'm actually suggesting that
I'd like to smack you in the back
or I'm saying you should pet the horse
or who knows right I mean there's all
this contingency involved in them and
when we think about how do we show how
we appear to others there that
contingency cannot be eliminated you
know the same thing to be said about
these these videos you see me walking
back and forth here in front of a
chalkboard I'm making fairly
conventional gestures on somebody who
just stick you lates a lot of the fairly
animate face my voice is not a monotone
it rises up and down you know I get
excited about things but do you really
know what's going on with me engaging
this taxi of some idea but I confront
you has this opaque sensuous unity and
if I could see you on the other side of
this like when I'm teaching in front of
a classroom of students let me tell you
you have a whole sea go Pig sensuous
unities out there you see somebody kind
of with all these staring at you they
might be deep in thought about what
you're saying or they might be thinking
about man I wish lunch was here order
they were about to fall asleep you don't
really know and we want to know we want
to grasp the universal that's part of
what this whole business is about he
also talks about this in terms of the
actual he talks about the obstinacy or
the intractability is another way of
translating it out of the actual again
when we're dealing with human beings
what it means to be actual as opposed to
merely virtual is that you become to a
certain extent although your
understandable not entirely predictable
if you were totally predictable then I
suppose you'd just be sort of a figment
and somebody's imagination right or you
know total slave I suppose
so he says you know the hope of becoming
one with this this now sensuous
individual as the universal what's
happening over here the contingent
individual is
gain some sort of unity with the
unchangeable individual by finding
itself within the unchangeable and
presumably finding others within the
unchangeable is this unity able to be
brought it all off can we just buy you
know thinking oh I I guess I am part of
the transcendent does that make us feel
like we are does that make us know that
we are does that automatically produce
in us of comportment of being through
acting in that way or does there still
remain a disjunction the disjunction
that Hegel is gonna say is almost
infinite he goes on and he says that
this hope of becoming one with it must
remain a hope the very nature of Hope so
long that lasts is that it hasn't been
attained it's lacking what he were
translating here as fulfillment or fool
on a kind of enjoyment of state where
things have actually happened the way
that the hope wants and it's landing
presence Ganga Mundt being president
didn't say so he says why between the
hope and the fulfillment stands
precisely the absolute contingency or
inflexible difference which lies in the
very assumption of definite form so it's
not only here it's also here in the
assumption of definite form which was
the ground of Hope so there's there's a
kind of paradox here hope arises
precisely because we moved from this
state to this day and then we're like
alright now now I can I can wrap my head
around the transcendent because there it
is it's that guy or it's this thing or
it's these words or something like that
something I can I can actually look at
or at least you know experience in some
way and then we start to hope for this
unity of ourselves with it and that who
doesn't get realized and Hegel says this
in pretty long summer terms at the end
he says by the nature of this
immediately present unit through the
actual existence in which it has clothed
itself right so the transcendent is
there it Nesser that necessarily follows
it in the
the time it has vanished and that it's
space it had a remote existence and
remains utterly remote what does he mean
by that
what he means is that insofar as we're
hoping we're not a team and for the time
being we're stuck in this realm of hope
and non-attainment so whether the divine
takes a human form it stands right in
front of me so close that I could smell
the garlic on a thread you know and
talks to me and looks me up you know
eyeballs me and stuff like that it's
there but it also remains light-years
away from me this is not a stage in
which the unhappy consciousness becomes
hamming this stuff this is this tells
you quite a bit about why the unhappy
consciousness should in fact these so
upset and unhappy and on restful
attempting further and further to
penetrate into this beyond